people who are happy passionate and
successful are everywhere right can't we
just turn to them to see what they did
to get there
not quite a few years ago gallup
conducted an international poll that
included questions about workplace
happiness and engagement how many people
said they felt engaged at work was it a
65
b 35
or c 15
if you guessed a you're way off the
answer is c
only 15 percent of people worldwide said
they felt engaged at work that means
that eighty-five percent of people
around the world don't find meaning and
purpose in what they do considering that
according to writer gemma curtis we
spend 13 years and two months of our
lives at work that's a lot of time being
upset but when we look around we see a
different story right social media posts
show people pursuing their dreams and
living their best lives and news and
interviews showcase entrepreneurs
stumbling on that great idea creating a
company and selling it all before age 25
yet as we just saw the statistics don't
bear this out in japan a whopping 94 of
survey respondents said that they're not
engaged at work it's a bit better in the
us but not much only 30 percent of
workers say they're happier with their
work this is colliding with what gallup
says is an increased focus on the value
of work among millennials they want a
job and a career that's dream worthy
keep dreaming it's worth a shot so in a
world that's so unhappy at work how do
we make that dream come true there's a
single powerful secret i'm going to
share that will help you sort it all out
there's a zen story about two monks
standing in the garden of the monastery
watching some prayer flags waving in the
distance one monk comments the wind is
moving the other monk shakes his head no
he says it's the flags that are moving a
senior monk walks by and the two monks
ask his opinion he said you are both
wrong it is your mind that is moving
that's the powerful secret that in life
it's actually less about what you
experience and more about how you
experience it that's important the truth
is actually less about what job you have
and more about how you do it that shapes
the quality of your life that actually
makes a lot of sense katrina lake didn't
know what to do after college so she
decided to work at a consulting firm it
was there that she became curious about
what would happen if you married
technology with clothing retail her
initial idea flopped but she kept
exploring going on to work for a venture
capital firm then on to business school
finally lake had her big idea she would
marry personal shopping with online
clothes buying she started shopping for
her friends and keeping meticulous data
about what they liked and didn't and why
business plan and spreadsheets in hand
she began to search for funding and was
turned down by more than 50 different
venture capitalists that didn't stop her
though periodically she would get just
enough money to keep going and building
her idea in 2017 lake became the
youngest woman in history to take a
company public and in 2020 stitch fix
was valued at 3.37 billion dollars lake
did an interview with the podcast
skimmed from the couch and was asked the
worst piece of advice she'd ever gotten
what was it follow your dreams lake says
the notion that your job should be your
dream job is misleading so many parts of
this job have not been a dream she said
whether it was struggling to raise money
cramming to get stitch fix boxes out the
door on time or being the one who had to
go out and buy a new printer when theirs
broke down here's the thing you can be a
stock broker who makes millions of
dollars but is miserable or you can be a
grocery clerk who changes others life
simply with your kindness and caring the
difference lies in how you approach life
and that difference comes from your
motivation need motivation watch a top
10 with believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best jay shetty and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
[Music]
rule number two manage time
intelligently according to writer gemma
curtis each of us has on average 28
835 days in our lives of that time we
spend 33 years in bed seven of them
trying to fall asleep one year and four
months exercising unless you're my wife
i'm guessing we'll spend something like
five years exercising she loves it we
spend 11 years and four months on
non-work screen time and eight years and
four months of that is spent watching tv
with the rest on social media in fact we
spend six times longer watching tv and
two times longer on social media than
exercising yet experts say that even
just 10 minutes of exercise a day would
increase the overall quality of our
sleep 10 minutes see how it's all
interconnected we'll also spend about
three years on vacation that might sound
like a lot but compare that to the 13
years and two months we'll spend at work
unless you're elon musk who says he
spent 15 years working 100 hours or more
a week he's been known to sleep under
his desk ladies most of you will spend
about 136 days getting ready guys it's
about 46 days for you unless you're me
we spent four years and six months
eating 66 percent of workers say they
eat meals at their desks we spend 235
days waiting in line after all of that
it's no wonder that we spend just one
year and three days of our lives
socializing but here's some good news we
spend about 115 days of our lives
laughing it's pretty shocking right who
knew we were spending so much time on
things we probably don't really care
about and so little on the things we do
here's the thing and i say this in my
book think like a monk no matter what
you think your values are your actions
tell the real story sure there are
things we have to do like go to work but
when we have free time we dedicate that
time to what we value you may say and
even believe that you value time with
your partner or your kids most of all
but when you have spare time you're more
often scrolling on your phone or with
your friends there's a well-known saying
by ben franklin and it's worth
remembering it goes when you take care
of the minutes the hours will take care
of themselves when we don't spend our
time on what we value mostly that's not
on purpose it's because we're simply not
paying attention part of that is because
for a lot of us by the time we have
spare time we're wiped out and it's just
hard to get motivated to change gears i
need my sleep the other reason we waste
time is we discount the value of our
minutes you're probably familiar with
the dreaded time gap that's what i call
the mysterious black hole where our
missing time goes you know when you're
at work and you sit down to do something
but then a headline pops up on your news
alerts and you click on it and the next
you look at the clock it's 45 minutes
later and you don't know where the time
went or when you get home and you're
about to change your clothes to get some
exercise but first you just want to
forward this hilarious meme to a friend
and then all of a sudden 90 minutes have
gone by and you're still sitting on your
couch i must have lost track of time we
lose time because we treat our minutes
like dimes a dime isn't worth much to
most right it's just like 10 cents if we
were walking down the street and saw a
dime most of us wouldn't even stop to
pick it up according to data from
provision living the average american
spends 324 minutes on their phone every
day if you measured that in dimes over a
single day you'd have enough money to
pay for a drop in yoga or meditation
class over seven days you'd have enough
to pay for organic groceries for a week
for two people over a month you could
take a long weekend at a deluxe airbnb
but let's say you didn't spend those
dimes but instead put them in a basic
savings account by the end of the year
you'd have
and
11
six dollars but forget dimes in actual
minutes if you spend just an hour less
on your mobile phone per day you'd have
an extra twenty one thousand nine
hundred minutes per year that's a lot of
time saved and a lot more time to do the
things that support you your health your
well-being along with the other things
and people you value rule number three
avoid negativity it's one of the biggest
and most common things that wears us out
and weighs us down every single day
starting from the time we wake up
negativity doesn't it often feel like
everywhere you look most of the
headlines and social media posts even
messages from your friends and family
are negative why does it seem like no
matter where we turn negativity is just
coming at us from every direction i'm
not about that negativity when it comes
to negativity research tells us some
interesting things about human behavior
scientists from mcgill university set up
a study that participants were told was
about observing their eye tracking
patterns while they read news from a web
page really the scientists just wanted
to see which articles the participants
picked and overwhelmingly it was
negative articles but why another study
reported in week showed that on average
negative headlines outperformed positive
headlines by 63 percent and data from
pew research says that two-thirds of
americans say they feel worn out by the
sheer amount of news that's out there
just the quantity is tiring and negative
it's way too much it's just too
much researchers also estimate that up
to 80 of our thoughts every day are
negative so i'm gonna give you three
ways to lighten your negativity load so
you can start feeling more energized and
positively engaged scientists have
concluded that our over consumption of
negativity is due at least in part to
something called negativity bias we're
wired to detect threats so we give more
of our attention to things that are
negative so let's say you're out on a
hike in a gorgeous location there might
be 99 beautiful things to take in about
your surroundings the birds the trees
the cascading waterfall but the second
you hear a little rustle in the bushes
all of your attention will go to that
one sound because your brain is worried
it can be a threat did you hear that
there's also research that sheds some
light on what encourages negativity in
our social circles according to
neuroscientists certain receptors for
dopamine the reward chemical actually
become unavailable when we don't give a
socially desirable response to others if
your friends say let's go to the abc
grill for lunch you're more likely to
get that feel dopamine hit if you say
sounds great even if that's not what you
want to eat our brains want us to fit in
if you've ever participated in gossip or
other negative behavior and then
wondered why you did that this helps to
explain it i feel better about myself
the negativity odds may feel like
they're stacked against us but we really
can decrease the negativity in our lives
and we do it through small simple
choices made consistently going along
with your friends even though you
disagree is like someone offering you a
sugary candy bar it's hard to resist and
taste great at the moment but later you
feel the weight of that choice when
you're burned out tired potentially
depressed i made a mistake that food
analogy can be helpful when looking at
the negativity in our lives like junk
food junk thoughts and junk behavior are
weighing us down if i'm giving myself a
steady diet of refined sugar and
processed food if that's what i'm
ingesting i'm going to be tired and
cranky i'm awake i'm awake
but if i eat lots of fresh produce if
i'm consuming things that are more
positive i'm going to feel energized
i'll feel more motivated my mood will be
better and my thoughts will be clearer
and that makes it easier to make healthy
decisions it's self-perpetuating have
you ever found it when you're tired you
eat worse when you eat worse you're more
tired if our daily diet is made up of
judgment and anger we're going to feel
terrible we won't be as creative and we
won't feel inspired studies even show we
won't be as physically healthy because
people who are mostly negative get sick
more often rule number four find your
core values it all starts in childhood
we want to be loved and accepted that's
completely normal but because of this
need for love and acceptance from just a
few years of age we begin to live
according to what others want for and
from us we form ideas about who and how
we should be based on what parts of us
our behavior and personality are welcome
and praised and which are not i like
that about him we also learn by
imitating what we see others doing as we
grow older we shape our likes and
dislikes according to the people we
surround ourselves with for example
according to data from adweek among 18
to 34 year olds 68 said that their peers
social media posts were at least
somewhat likely to influence them to
make a purchase i i got one for myself
see soon these attitudes and behaviors
we're imitating become indistinguishable
to us from who we really are what
america in a pair of studies researchers
reviewed data from three different
seasons of the premier league football
play and concluded that referees
systematically favored home teams by
shortening close games where the home
team is ahead and lengthening close
games when the home team is behind the
reason
pressure from the home crowd so when it
comes to making decisions we change our
own picture of reality to avoid the
discomfort that comes when we go against
what others think and that's just
strangers imagine the influence of our
friends our families and co-workers and
the effect they have on us yeah but i'm
your brother we're family what finally
does make us question our thoughts and
behavior is often that we hit a wall
maybe we wake up one day and realize
we're dreading going to work maybe we're
sitting with a group of friends and
suddenly we think what am i doing here i
don't fit in with these people and then
we end up asking even more powerful
questions like what do i want to do with
my life and who am i really as
billionaire investor warren buffett once
said chains of habit are too light to be
felt until they are too heavy to be
broken and maybe that's how you feel
like you're being weighed down by this
version of you that you've been
pretending to be or had to be because of
life imagine your life was an empty jar
if you're filling that job with ideas
and beliefs that are not yours you're
living a life that isn't yours the first
type of filler we put in our lives that
blocks us from knowing ourselves is
other people's opinions so many of us
are in constant disconnect with
ourselves because we're always
validating or verifying others opinions
of us so
what do you think we let others ideas
and beliefs define how we feel instead
of being guided by our own values
following others opinions blindly can
quickly get us lost before i decided to
become a monk i was training to be an
investment banker or working business
when i stopped to look at why i was
chasing this career that i wasn't really
interested in i realized i was following
my community's definition of success and
not my own this isn't me step back and
ask yourself why am i doing this is it
because it's what you truly want or is
it because it's societies or someone
else's opinion of what you should do or
want if you want to know yourself and if
you want to experience meaning and
purpose this is the kind of stuff you
want to fill your life with your values
should come first when you isolate your
values you'll start to see more clearly
what's important to you you'll start to
get a sense of your passion and your
purpose and you'll be able to start to
see and understand what choices will
bring you closer to the life of your
dreams also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five connect with
intrinsic motivation social scientist
tim casa studies values and goals
including two types of motivation
extrinsic such as for money image or
status and intrinsic such as for
personal growth close relationships and
making the world a better place he and
his colleagues have consistently found
that people who place a high value on
extrinsic versus intrinsic goals are
less happy and report lower levels of
satisfaction with life along with higher
levels of anxiety and depression and
external rewards can even decrease the
internal motivation you already have
researchers took a group of kids at a
nursery school who had a natural love of
drawing in one group the children were
just left to draw in another they were
told they could earn a good player award
which included a ribbon and a
certificate if they drew a picture two
weeks later the same kids were offered
the opportunity to draw pictures those
who are allowed to just draw showed the
same high level of interest in drawing
the second time around but those who
were told they could earn a reward by
drawing a picture the first time around
were half as likely to want to draw
another picture
what's in it for me the external reward
actually made them less motivated to
draw when we do things out of intrinsic
motivation we're more likely to find
meaning and purpose in our lives and our
work for katrina lake it was her love of
data along with wanting to answer the
question
what could the future of retail look
like here are three ways to connect with
your intrinsic motivation first live for
who you want to become create a vision
of who you want to be in five years in
that vision of yourself list out five
ways you're feeling about your life and
your work and your relationships are you
excited joyful satisfied fulfilled
driven confident be as specific as
possible now for the next week every
time you make a choice ask yourself if
that choice will bring you closer to or
take you further away from that vision
of yourself in five years do you want to
play a video game or read a book do you
want to watch a movie or have a
conversation do you want to take a class
or
waste time scrolling on social media hey
there's nothing wrong with any of the
things i said i love them all but we
need the right ratio we need to make
sure that more of our steps are leading
us towards who we want to be then away
it's simple math tip number two is
discover where you can connect something
you're already doing or have a natural
strength or inclination for to something
you're passionate about that connection
point your passion doesn't have to pay
you but if your current job can pay your
passion
that might just be as good and a good
start check this out when computer
science professor louis von on set out
to create dulingo he had one motivation
to make learning free as a kid growing
up in poverty he saw so many kids who
didn't have access to quality education
so he and a partner created duolingo a
language learning app that's now used by
more than 40 million people worldwide
and while the company has become
tremendously profitable ahn's motivation
was never about making money it was
about giving back that's major intrinsic
motivation connecting your passion with
a larger purpose one of my greatest
loves and one of the things that
motivates me is learning and that's the
third tip learning to love learning and
no matter what you do in life you cannot
fail if you look at every situation and
ask yourself what can i learn here
you're going to experience two things
you get to feel curiosity or and wonder
three things that research shows
contribute to feeling satisfaction and
meaning in your life and second if
you're always focused on learning you
will never be disappointed because even
when something doesn't go the way you'd
hoped or planned you can learn from it
as katrina lake says i think a lot of
people find themselves unhappy in their
jobs because it's not their dream but i
think at the end of the day
if you're learning and if you're working
with great people
that's going to be a rewarding
experience and that's how you too
can have a rewarding fulfilling
purposeful life and career rule number
six practice gratitude have you ever had
that vacation that you've been getting
ready for that you've been so psyched
about and by the time you're ready
packing getting ready to leave what's
happening
stress right you're running around like
what do i pack did we put out the note
for the dog sitter where's our uber all
right's here i know my wife and i can
have our moments when we're both trying
to tie things up and get ready for some
time off and it's ridiculous right that
that's how we're starting out as we set
out on our journey this new year
let's spend some time and energy
deliberately setting our mindset we're
going to do it with gratitude and here's
how writer marcel proust once said let
us be grateful for the people who make
us happy they are the charming gardeners
who make our souls blossom kelly
mcgonagall is a professor and researcher
at stanford university and her work
centers on this idea that stress is
neither good nor bad it's our reaction
to it that matters she says that one of
the most effective positive ways we can
deal with stress is to practice
gratitude but not just any kind of
gratitude specifically she says that
it's the gratitude that focuses on
others and their impact on our lives
that's most effective dr mcgonagall says
that stress is designed to motivate us
to get us to do something in the case of
the stress of loneliness for example
it's designed to move us to connect and
when we can feel gratitude for things
others have done for us it helps us feel
more hopeful more willing to seek help
and support and to offer help and
support to others sounds like an amazing
mindset to start out with right yeah it
does
so every day for one week each morning
when you get up spend three to five
minutes diving deep into one beautiful
or meaningful thing someone has done for
you in your life be specific you're
grateful to your mom for helping you
with your homework or you're grateful
for your best friend in fifth grade for
that time he stood up to someone who is
bullying you and of course it can be
something in recent memory too be sure
to remember the sights sounds and smells
and what was said so you can really
reinforce that memory in your body and
in your brain rule number seven turn
pain into progress beth canopic
understands
eight years ago she lost her 16 year old
daughter lyanna when suddenly and
inexplicably a virus lyanna contracted
migrated to her heart
it could not be cured
after a tumultuous month in the hospital
beth's vibrant joyful athletic daughter
was gone
it's every parent's worst nightmare and
as you'd imagine it catapulted beth into
what seemed like bottomless grief
and yet last year something incredible
happened beth gathered 14 other mothers
in and around her florida town who had
all lost children for lunch she says
there wasn't a dry eye in the room only
the tears weren't from sadness they were
from joy somehow each one of these
mothers some of whom had lost more than
one child were able to share positive
loving memories of their children along
with the beautiful ways their lives had
changed as a result of their profound
loss of course every one of these women
would rather have had their children
back
but remarkably they were able to take
what had happened and allow something
powerful
to grow from it as one of my good
friends ray dalio says pain plus
reflection equals progress rule number
eight follow your curiosity the first
thing
is that purpose is like an adult right
finding your purpose is like an adult in
terms of growth passion is like a
teenager but before you become a
teenager what are you you're a child
child is like the interest and before
you're a child you're a baby that's
curiosity
so at the baby stage of passion what you
first need is curiosity that curiosity
turns into an interest that interest
turns into a passion that passion turns
into a purpose for so many of us we get
stuck trying to be like well what's my
passion it's like saying well i should
be a teenager before i'm even a baby
let's first learn to crawl before we
learn to walk or run or fly
so when we start that we ask yourself
what am i curious about what could i
watch documentaries about forever what
could i get excited about learning
forever what is it that i keep getting
up to do even if i fail what is it that
i get motivated to learn about or hear
about or read about or watch about even
when i don't know so much about it what
are you naturally curious about and
drawn towards in your life that is the
birthplace of your passion it doesn't
have to be a passion just yet it just
needs to be a curiosity or an interest
rule number nine tune up your
self-awareness when you're going on a
long car trip you take your car to the
mechanic first right to get things
recalibrated realigned and ready to go
that's our second m how we're going to
recalibrate for our new journey is to
adjust our self-awareness neuroscientist
david eagleman says that as far as our
brains are concerned as adults we are
more like our peers than our childhood
selves yet when we think about who we
are we mostly base our ideas on our
younger self so
tune up your self awareness you're going
to go on a date gathering expedition
among those who know you best simon
sinek the author of start with y has a
great exercise for this when people say
i don't know what i'm good at or i don't
really know what my unique abilities are
that's because it can be hard to get an
accurate picture of yourself from the
inside right
there's a saying that you can't read the
label from inside the jar so you're
going to ask people outside your jar to
help you out can you help me you're
going to ask three to five people who
know you well it may be personal
professional friends to describe for you
what makes you special ask them simon
recommends why are you friends with me
why did you pick me as your partner or
what makes me stand out as an employee
what do you really like about me as your
parent now beware most people will
answer first with something general
you're smart you're funny you're a good
listener that's not deep enough anything
else ask for more for example lots of
people are funny why are you friends
with me instead of someone else who's
funny or lots of employees are dedicated
can you give me more detail like a
specific incident or example that really
showed you that tell me more then you'll
start getting the truly helpful data and
information such as
i love the way you use humor to make
other people feel welcome and
comfortable or you have this ability to
take our discussions deeper by bringing
in insights from lots of other fields
that's very nice of you to say you start
to see yourself through others eyes and
get an understanding of what's working
what your strengths are that you can go
deeper on and maximize and what makes
you
uniquely you here's an awesome idea
convene a feel-good roundtable in person
or over zoom with a few good friends or
family members or even do this with
co-workers where you go around and tell
each other some of your greatest
strengths in detail then you're
spreading the love and the joy and the
support as well and it doesn't feel as
awkward as just asking it for yourself
please don't make this awkward for me
okay so what else do we need to start a
journey strong we need some idea of
where we're going right
a map
that's our third end you just learned
about all these great things you've got
going for you but no doubt you also have
an area or two or twelve that's me where
you'd like to grow so we're going to
create a map of how to get there and one
way you can do that is to pick a mentor
someone who embodies that quality or
those qualities you're looking to grow
this year one of my greatest mentors is
martin luther king jr specifically the
way he inspired people for a meaningful
course and connected people to his
powerful words maybe if you want to
become better at relating to others your
mentor is oprah winfrey maybe if you
want to be more strategic and thoughtful
when it comes to business it's your
father or mother that was the case for
john mackey the founder of whole foods
his father was his business mentor for
years maybe if you want to cultivate
innovation or persistence your mentor is
someone like sir james dyson or richard
branson next figure our basic simple
ways to connect with your mentor
regularly if it's not someone you can
connect with in real life you can read
their work watch their videos listen to
a podcast read about their lives tape an
inspiring fact about them or quote from
them above your desk or put it into your
wallet remember it's not that you want
to mimic your mentor you want to be
yourself and combine those strengths
you're developing with those great
strengths you already have in place but
if you look at some of the geography
your mentor has traveled it can help
provide you with your own map for
developing those strengths and number 10
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is stop wasting money in a
2019 employee survey at pwc 71 of
millennials said their money stress had
gone up over the past year it is
stressing
me out and nearly half of all
respondents said that they spend three
hours or more every week thinking about
or trying to sort out their finances and
money woes don't just affect us
individually 44 of young adults said
that the money is the number one
stressor in their relationship i need to
borrow some money and check out these
stats according to erin lowry creator of
the broke millennial blog the average
millennial graduated with 37 000 in
student debt that's in the states and
some have much more that's enough to buy
a brand new car or put a down payment on
a house maybe you're like yeah don't
remind me jay hey i get it lots of us
come from tough places financially and
you might be there now growing up my
family definitely was not what you'd
call wealthy for some of us the hard
times actually help spur us on to
success here's one of the stories that's
really inspired me it's of a young man
who at 14 was evicted with his mother
from their apartment and couldn't afford
a place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
american football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
nfl career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today dwayne
the rock johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that's why he named his company seven
bucks productions still even if you
don't have aspirations of becoming a
mega movie star financial security is
within reach and the place to start is
to stop wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what i'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple financial expert
sus allman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body
okay never mind you get it anyway orman
says that if you invested that 100 or
more per month so many of us spend on
coffee in a roth retirement account over
40 years with compound interest you'd
have a million dollars
that's worth making your own coffee
right actually the entire category of
food and drink is a big one not only do
we spend loads of money eating out for
dinner another big money waster people
often overlook is lunch here's a quick
quiz how much do you think the average
person spends on lunch in a year
according to visa is it
a
520
b 1280
and c
2
746 dollars
if you guess c you're right the average
person spends 2
746 per year on lunches now check this
out if instead of buying lunch you
invested that money every month in a
basic savings account over 20 years
you'd have i hope you're sitting down
because this is unbelievable you'd have
60
760 dollars and 41 cents i'm going to
sit down and that's just with basic
compounding interest okay so here's
another big way we waste money buying
new now here's the thing i know for lots
of us i'll be honest myself included how
we look is important you enjoy fashion
but you can continue to have your unique
look and have favorite brands and still
spend less money on clothing here's a
way to do that i have another friend
who's into designer brands but would
never pay designer prices her secret is
to shop at consignment stores and now
that there are lots of these stores
online there are tons of items to choose
from and you can even shop by your
favorite brands the other month i
complimented my friend on a sweater and
she told me she got it for 65
less than the original price and it came
brand new with the tag still attached
plus shopping consignment also benefits
the environment because we're
recirculating clothes instead of just
making more stuff beyond clothing there
are loads of things we tend to buy brand
new that we really don't need to for
example if your iphone breaks you can
actually buy a refurbished one directly
from apple for way less money and they
come with a warranty and don't get me
started on cars here's another quiz when
you drive a new car off the lot it
literally immediately loses a certain
percentage of its value what percentage
is it a
5
b
10
or c
30
the answer is b
according to carfax the second you drive
a new car off the lot it loses at least
10 percent in value over the first year
it loses about 20 of its value that
means if you spend 30 000 on a brand new
car within a year it's worth only 24 000
and the value just keeps going down
instead of needing everything brand new
look at what you can buy used or borrow
from someone you know and that's another
way we waste money we buy things
immediately we think of it we get all
excited we go online and buy it it's
like when the apple watch first came out
and i went out and bought one i was so
stoked but no offense to the product i
discovered pretty quickly just in time
to give it back that i didn't actually
need it i ended up returning it
take it back instead of impulse buying
that's your purchases if you say oh i
need to buy that whatever it may be and
then go to amazon and buy it and then
later in the day i wanted to get some of
that other thing i love and then going
to amazon or another store to buy that
what happens when you get your card
statement it all adds up and you're like
whoa how did i spend that much money i
don't remember any of that and that's
because 15 here and ten dollars there
doesn't seem like much of the time
especially when you're using a credit
card or other digital payment because
you don't see the money you don't feel
it you don't actually have that
experience of giving it away or holding
on to it instead when you think of
something you need and i'm putting need
in quotes because it might not be a real
need but i want put it in your cart and
leave it there or write it down on a
list don't buy it right away then at
some specified time like the end of the
week look at your list or your cards and
choose what it is you really need that
will give you a better idea of what
you're actually spending and what you
actually need versus what you want
at 18 i was really fortunate when i met
a monk and this monk was invited to
speak and i kind of just went because
one of my friends forced me to at that
time i was listening to ceos and
entrepreneurs and business people and
marketers who who i thought that's what
i was aspiring to be like
and then i hear this monk
and he captivated me like no one had
ever captivated me before
it was like staring at the most
beautiful woman on the planet you know i
was completely fixated on him and his
message see we live in echo chambers
we're just surrounded by the same
thinking how often do you bump into a
monk you know it just doesn't happen you
don't have no one has a dinner party and
goes oh yeah we just invited the monk
you know from town like the local monk
like no one ever does that and so we
meet people who are just like us most of
the time
and we talk about this in business all
the time if you want to be a billionaire
spend time with billionaires if you want
to be a millionaire spend time with
millionaires if you want to be a tech
startup spend time with you know that's
that's the common rhetoric that we hear
all the time
but what if you want to find purpose and
master the mind there's no one better
than a monk who's mastered the mind
so for me the first step is just opening
yourself up to new experiences and new
role models because most of us can't see
ourselves
in people so then we try and fit
ourselves into the boxes that we do see
and and i mean there's this beautiful
quote that i've been saying it
everywhere and i wish i wrote it but i
didn't so it's by a philosopher and
writer named cooley
and he said that today i'm not what i
think i am i'm not what you think i am
i am what i think you think i am
right and just let that blow your mind
for a moment it's uh it's so powerful
i'm not what i think i am i'm not what
you think i am
i am what i think you think i am
so we live in this perception of a
perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think i should be my identity is
made up by what my college or university
thinks i should achieve
while you're living in that bubble in
that echo chamber getting to what you
really want to do is impossible
because maybe that just doesn't fit and
i think so many people feel that way
today that they don't fit into the
current education system they don't fit
with the three or four or five careers
that you're taught exist
so that process of self-excavation and
actualization first requires being
exposed you can't be what you can't see
if i never saw a monk i would never have
wanted to be a monk if i never meet a
billionaire i wouldn't want to be one
because i wouldn't know what that feels
like i don't know what it looks like i
don't know what it takes
and and i think that's the biggest
challenge of our society that we're not
exposed so that's the first step being
exposed to unique experiences and role
models second step is finding that
experience or role model that you're
passionate about and exactly like you
said taking it seriously shadow their
network with them spend time with them
observe them even from afar it takes
that observation being addicted to
observing that person's lifestyle
and then the third step is going yes or
no
does that work for me
not everyone who's gonna go off and
become a monk is gonna feel like the way
i did and that's cool
but not everyone is going to go and
follow and shadow a billionaire and go
that's exactly the lifestyle i want they
may want the result but do they want the
hard work that goes with it and so for
me that's the third step it's observing
focusing shadowing getting as close to
the process of that individual and then
going yes or no do i want that process
not do i want the result
everyone wants to be that monk who's
fully enlightened you know can walk
through has an incredible aura that
people just gravitate towards but when
you realize he has to wake up at 2 a.m
every day and sleeps about four to six
hours you're like ah you know i don't
want to do it
that doesn't sound like me fred smith
was an undergraduate at yale university
in
1965. as part of his coursework he wrote
an economics paper exploring the
transportation of goods in the united
states it's how things get delivered to
you and me he found that shippers were
transporting large packages and items
either via truck or through passenger
airplanes he thought he had a more
efficient method he wrote a last-minute
paper as you do about how a company
transporting small items via plane would
be a much better business model because
he was rushed he never really got around
to explaining in the paper how that
company would run and he ended up
getting a c the funny thing is he still
didn't give up and in 1971 he actually
launched the company he was speaking
about but within three years of founding
the company federal express as it was
called was actually on the verge of
bankruptcy they were losing over a
million a month that was because of
rising fuel costs competitors in the
same market and at its zenith it was
only worth about five thousand dollars
smith even made a final pitch to general
dynamics hoping for more funding and it
was rejected most people at this point
probably would have just shut down
rejection the grade c losing a million a
month but fred smith had different ideas
smith actually ended up flying to las
vegas that weekend with all of what the
company had the five thousand dollars
the monday morning after the company had
thirty two thousand dollars thanks to
his blackjack skills that money made it
possible to cover fuel costs for just a
few days more soon after the company was
able to raise significant funds he went
around to multiple places to find
sponsors investors people that believed
in what he was trying to achieve as a
service the amazing thing is that he was
creating a company that we all know
today it's called fedex it now operates
in over 220 countries and has an annual
revenue of over 45 billion dollars the
interesting lesson that we can learn
here is that there were countless
occasions in fred smith's life where he
could have said that's it it's not
working for me he could have stopped
when he got that c for the paper he
could have stopped when he was losing a
million a month he could have even
stopped when he finally only had enough
to just last a few more days but he
believed in his vision he had belief he
had conviction about his idea and the
process and the service that he was
creating and that's the lesson here if
you really want to achieve something
you'll find a way and if you don't
you'll find excuses most of us just
throw ourselves into the deep end
and then try swim and figure it out
right monk life actually
begins at like five years old like the
training of monk life is ultimately
training in self-actualization and
self-awareness
it's meant to start when you're five the
problem is we all went to normal schools
that try to put stuff in us rather than
take stuff out of us it's crazy you talk
about this right right right like
you you know you were told at school
that you weren't very good and you
weren't good at english and now you have
a new york times bestseller right yeah
and it and it's like but no one noticed
that potential inside you no one noticed
that oh louis was really creative right
and you're not the only person there's
so many people who feel like that so the
modern schooling system didn't
extrapolate your
self-actualization your element and just
try to put maths english science inside
so the point is that you're trying to
get to such a strong foundation that
when you interact in the world you're
going with a sense of strength fuel
energy to make a difference rather than
going into the world and then going oh
my god where am i trying to figure it
out and i find what happens today is
that when you don't we all know this we
i mean self-love has become such a big
thing now that when people don't figure
out yeah it's like a huge train now but
but my point is that if you don't start
at a place where you have self-awareness
self-actualization
you have figured out what works for you
what your strengths are
how you want to be in an environment
when you walk out there most of us just
pretend to be someone else most of us
get lost most of us get carried away
yeah so my point is
strengthen yourself grow yourself and
then of course interact with the world
let me tell you about this girl called
cleo i think you might know someone like
her too she had the dream of becoming a
model she said she was going to move to
la to pursue it seriously she took care
of herself at least her body well
someone told me she did ads for l'oreal
she had so many followers on instagram
who all loved her within a minute of her
posting a picture there would be
hundreds and hundreds of comments all
telling her how beautiful she was how
good she looked
comment after comment like after like
she was a real entertainer she was
always making everyone laugh
i remember every guy wanted her number
but she kept to herself she just had
this infectious energy
she got along with everyone she was
always the life of the party she was
never seen in the same outfit twice
boxes and boxes of amazon prime on
instagram she was the perfect girl with
the perfect life
the perfect world with the perfect guys
but nothing's perfect right it seemed
like she was always having the best time
with her friends always traveling new
experiences and so many great stories to
share until people started to notice
i think she lived like two lives no one
really knew her inside she had everyone
to text but no one to talk to
everyone to follow
but no one to walk with when the phone
was up her world was a stage when it was
down a reality came she had an invite to
every event but still felt lonely
she had all the friends in the world but
still felt no one really knows me she
was going through pain but never showed
that side
it was something she hid from the world
or maybe we just never asked
she had masked her sadness with what
looked like the ideal life
she was always flying high in the air
but felt low inside
her inbox was always full
but she felt empty within she was happy
on the outside
but struggling with depression and
anxiety
she had an addiction that everyone
called a lifestyle
but she was struggling with mental
health
but people were just occupied by her
physical appearance
see people think depression is sadness
people think
depression is crying
people think depression is being quiet
depression is when we smile
but we want to cry
it's when we talk
but we want to be quiet
it's when we pretend like we're happy
but we're not
depression is not always obvious
she drank to drown her pain but the pain
learned how to swim
she was sick of crying tired of trying
smiling
but inside she was dying
it's amazing how we can think we know
someone and still not know them at all
i don't think we understand how
stressful it is to explain what's going
on in your head when you don't even
understand yourself
we use filters to lighten our photos
whilst we carry the heavy weight of
stress remember it's okay to have
highlight reels but make sure someone
knows how you really feel
it's okay to use face time but make sure
you spend quality time face to face
it's okay to have followers but make
sure you have true friends
don't live for the approval of others
document the moments you're most in love
with yourself
not just the moments you think people
will love the most when someone doesn't
post for a few days
we ask if they're okay
when someone posts every day
we assume they are tell people you love
them
be a trustworthy friend
tell them that they matter tell them
that they've survived a lot and they're
ready to thrive now people who care will
ask how you're doing
people who love you
will wait till you tell the truth and
that's why robin williams said i used to
think that the worst thing in life was
to end up alone
it's not
the worst thing in life is to end up
with people who make you feel alone just
around two years ago i had this idea i
wanted to share wisdom at a pace we
wanted entertainment i wanted to share
wisdom in a way that it could connect
resonate and deeply evolve the lives of
people all over the world for 10 years
before that i've been working with
individuals groups coaching at
universities companies and all of these
opportunities but i really wanted to
serve and connect with everyone across
the world i wanted to make wisdom
accessible to anyone who had one of
these i have one of those so i was
excited i had the energy the enthusiasm
and i was pitching my idea to every
single company that was online now
remember this is before i ever made a
single video before any of you knew who
i was who's this guy i applied to not 10
not 20 but 30 online media companies
hoping that one of them would like my
series idea i waited a day i waited two
days i waited a week i was rejected
by every single one of those companies
before interview none of them invited me
for a phone interview none of them
invited me for a video interview none of
them even connected with me in any
personal way that's rude
i said to myself it doesn't matter let's
see what else i can do to try and make
my goal a reality what else you get
so i tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance i got
one answer from one answer only they
said you're getting older now most of
the people who want to break into this
industry around 21 years old just don't
worry about it other people said to me
look you need to go get a media and
journalism degree or a masters and then
we'll take you seriously literally i was
getting rejected from every single
person i spoke to but inside of me i had
this desire i had this calling i had
this mission i had this vision that i
wanted to share everything that i'd
learned with people out there i
genuinely tried every single possible
method i could to break into the media
industry to the point that the only
thing that was left that i could try was
to start a social media channel and of
course you know the rest the most
incredible thing is that it reminds me
of a really powerful thought from thomas
edison he once said when you believe
you've exhausted all options remember
this you haven't
that thought stayed in my mind the whole
time what i learned from all of this
rejection from all of this failure from
all of these clear no's was one really
important thing and today i want to give
that as a gift to you me
if you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision we have to take the
responsibility to prove our worth before
we expect anyone to value our talent
when i started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when i
started putting my energy into that
space that's when people started to take
notice that's when people started to
listen that's when things started to
happen
this is nice it's when i decided to take
the responsibility for sharing what i
was passionate about with the world and
not waiting for someone external to
validate me or give me permission or
allow me to do that that's what made the
difference if you're feeling you've been
going through a lot of rejections ask
yourself this is your deeper passion and
calling making you want to move further
number two have you truly knocked on
every single door and number three are
you working hard on investing in your
expertise and passion so that you really
have something impactful to offer albert
einstein famously remarked in a
conversation with werner heisenberg
he said you know in the west we've built
a beautiful ship and in it it has all
the comforts
but actually the one thing that it
doesn't have is a compass and that's why
it doesn't know where it's going this
paradox of our times was propounded by
the dalai lama when he said we have
wider freeways but narrower viewpoints
we have taller buildings but shorter
tempers will smith said that we spend
money we haven't earned on things we
don't need to impress people we don't
like
and it's phenomenal how the same
technology that brings us close to those
are far away takes us far away from the
people that are actually close 30
billion whatsapp messages are sent per
day but 48 of people say that they feel
lonelier in general the paradox of our
times is that we have
more degrees but less sense more
knowledge but less judgment more experts
but less solutions it was martin luther
king who said that the irony of our
times is that we have guided missiles
but misguided men have you ever found it
perplexing that we've been all the way
to the moon and back but we struggled to
start a conversation across the road or
across the train and it's amazing that
bill gates was known as the
top earner in 2015 with a wealth of 79.2
billion but one in four ceos claim to be
struggling from depression and do we
actually thrive off this paradox is it
that this paradox actually makes the
media interesting it's what makes
journalism interesting and what makes
politics interesting it's what makes
television interesting is this paradox
actually what we feed off and what we
live off and what we talk about and
discuss in our circles
doesn't it seem that we've tried to
clean the air but polluted our soul
we've split the atom but not our
prejudice and we're aiming for higher
incomes but we have lower morals so i'm
hearing you ask how do we bring a change
how do we
dissect this paradox that exists in our
lives and it starts by us each of us
pressing pause pressing reset and then
pressing play again taking a moment to
become more conscious taking a moment to
become more aware taking a moment to
really reflect on the consequence the
implications of a misplaced word of an
unnecessary argument that we all know we
didn't need to have or to
speak to someone just slightly
differently in a different tone and a
different voice in a different empathy
with a different perspective just to
really connect with people on a
different level this thinking out loud
started from albert einstein and i'll
track back to him when he actually said
that the
problems we have today can't be solved
with the same thinking we used when we
once created them so actually we need to
research alternative teachings we need
to deep down
dig into those ancient books of wisdom
we need to go back to understanding if
there's anything written in those crease
pages of time that can actually reveal
more knowledge and more wisdom of how we
can transform our experience of light
today otherwise this paradox
means that every step forward we take
we're taking three backwards every time
in the manu smithi which i talk about
think like a monk it's a monk book
and in the verse it says when you
protect your purpose
your purpose protects you
now i wanna i wanna unpack that what i
mean by that is
your purpose is like a rare jewel
and a rare gemstone
and imagine you were walking around with
the most expensive diamond or jewel in
the world how would you protect it you
want to just like you want to just wait
out yeah yeah you want to wear it on
your chest like this like a baby holding
it yeah putting a pillow around a
blanket you do like yeah protect it you
protect it
and so your purpose is like that and
guess what people are gonna tell you
every day
that that jewel is not worth anything
they're gonna tell you that that jewel
is actually
valueless it doesn't have any
impact on your life they're going to try
and take away that value they're going
to tell you that there's another jewel
out there that you need to have more
value
and what ends up happening is you don't
i love the word look at the wording
protect your purpose you have to protect
it so what happens is your success grows
you get more opportunities more ideas
more things coming your way temptations
but they can all take you away from your
purpose distractions
and to me i'm repeating this for myself
because i'm like i just want to stick to
what i was born to do and i'm so
grateful that i get to do it i'm so
happy i get to do it and i want to keep
protecting it i don't want to get lost
in the waves you know you don't want to
just get chucked in the waves of the
ocean and just get lost and just not
know where you're going so for me when
you protect your purpose your purpose
protects you so that's been your biggest
lesson that's my biggest lesson why do
you feel like your purpose has been
maybe distracted
i don't think it has
but i'm saying it so it doesn't like
reminding you yeah i'm reminding myself
like i'm preaching to myself right now
especially being in hollywood and the
temptation of all these opportunities
out here totally and i think for me it's
a bigger lesson also because it gives me
more faith so i always encourage and
this is actually actually this is why
it's my biggest lesson i encourage so
many people that i coach so many people
i mentor obviously everyone in my
community and audience and everything
to go and follow that go and live that
purpose and i see time and time again
that when i see people
trying to live their purpose they are
protected that it things work when
you're playing in your dharma and your
purpose things work things move you feel
momentum they happen and i'm not saying
they happen without effort but they
happen they move whereas when you're not
you just constantly feel like you're
grinding up against
you know a war you can't plan your life
30 years ahead you don't need to and i
think that's a pressure that we put on
ourselves like oh my god what am i doing
what am i doing when i'm 50 and it's
like well actually hopefully you'll be
doing something that surprises you
and why not just let your life surprise
you constantly
why make it out like life is like linear
perfect journey we're like at 30 i'm
going to do this and have 40. i'm going
to do this and at 15 it's like well life
probably is not going to go like that
and that picture that you have rolling
because it won't fit in with what you're
experiencing that gap is the pressure
that you feel in your life
the reason i'm saying don't put purpose
on a pedestal
is because then purpose becomes this
heavy weight that you're carrying
and you're now like
judging yourself that you don't know it
and if you instead make your goal to
learn about purpose learn about meaning
explore yourself experiment grow
now it becomes like
oh i'm just experimenting i'm just
learning about myself
if you don't really have an interest
it's going to be really hard and when it
comes to our soft skills we go oh i'm a
good communicator i'm just going to
stick to that forget vulnerability or
i'm a really good talker forget
listening
and that kind of all comes in together
and i think the point is if we're always
learning and figuring out a way to serve
in whatever situation we're in
that's that's the best
route for success
because that's something that no one can
take away from you we like stress out
about not being motivated we stress out
about not finding purpose but guess what
just like you've got to eat and shower
you have to find purpose in every day
i think that we have to get as intimate
with our dark side as possible and i
feel like when you don't get that
intimacy you don't really understand it
i look back and i think why did i do
that and it's just always been my desire
to experiment always been my desire to
learn always been my desire to be
curious and find out more about myself
the first is to approach any situation
with compassion and empathy the other
thing is to recognize that sometimes
when we go through pain it makes us pay
attention
like when we go through pain it makes us
pay attention when things are going
great we often get complacent
we stop worrying we get lazy
we don't worry about anything we're just
relaxing and as soon as you feel pain
pain is a way of your body of society of
the economy to force you to pay
attention so if you're being lazy and
not eating right your body reacts badly
to tell you to stop doing that so any
pain that happens in your life first of
all is saving you from more pain
and so for me that's the shift that we
have to go through and that all comes
from us
deeply looking into our minds and going
where are these blocks turning up from
where are they coming from what are
their roots and then how can i replace
them with
the the right conversation the right
dialogue internally when it comes to
your hard skills focus on your strengths
when it comes to your soft skills focus
on your weaknesses if you do those two
things your life will change
dramatically because if you're good at
something you'll become exceptional at
it life is challenging it's full of ups
and downs we think i wish things could
just be still
i wish things would stop changing
i wish my problems would go away
we want a life that's steady with a path
that's flat
yet as deborah evans once said
life is like an ekg without the ups and
downs
you're not living
because this is what a flat line looks
like
and this is what a lifeline looks like
when we feel those highest highs those
extreme peaks
were ecstatic to be on the summit
then when we're in the lowest lows those
deep values were ready to submit
and so we try and play it safe and avoid
all risks
but when we seek security and prioritize
passiveness
we don't realize that a flat lifeline
means we're dead
if we're always trying to live our lives
at sea level then we'll never see what
life is truly about
that what we judge as good and bad
are in fact deeply connected
how could we ever experience how
wonderful happiness is
if we never felt sadness
how could we taste the triumph of
success
if we never failed how could we know the
comfort of gratitude
if we never experienced loss
somehow we got the idea that being
successful and moving forward in life
means we're constantly moving up
but have you ever read a book watched a
movie or seen a case study like that
they don't exist
every story worth telling has peaks and
valleys successes and setbacks
our brains are wired for novelty when
something's new whether it's a fantastic
surprise or a huge challenge our brains
light up we thrive on learning and our
opportunities to grow yet our brains
also easily become accustomed to
patterns making it harder for us to
change
dramatic disruptions help us break these
patterns and invite us to see and
experience the world in a whole new way
and as it turns out we're designed for
change all the way down to ourselves
your body is constantly being reinvented
replacing most of itself every 7 to 15
years even down to our bones
the universe is constantly shifting and
we are part of that when we try and
resist change it goes against our very
nature
in the journey of life we experience
pleasure and pain there will be sunshine
and rain there will be loss in gain but
we must learn to keep moving forward
again and again so if you open your eyes
this morning
if you were healthy enough to move about
to maybe get yourself some food
if you're able to go to a refrigerator
and find that it was full and stocked if
you were able to put on some clothes
and if you had a roof over your head
just remember how grateful you can be
for all those things we consider to be
basic but for others
they don't even have access to
we can't stop life's ups and downs but
we can change how we experience them
we can learn to go with life's flow
because as helen keller once said life
is either a daring adventure
or nothing at all i think one of my
first things in failure
is
don't take it more personally than it
actually is and i'll give an example of
that when i was applying to
40 companies that all rejected me before
an interview yeah
all i was getting was an automated
response
saying your application will not go any
further
i can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a
interaction with me they just saw my
name they saw i'd been a monk for three
years
that resume is useless i mean what's
your transferable skills like sitting in
silence and stillness
surprise surprise no one wants to hire a
monk and so they rejected you but that's
not personal because they didn't meet me
in person but what if they had me right
so that's the first thing the first step
is don't take all fear failure i'll give
an example me and you
we reach out to countless guests to be
on our podcast we say no all the time
who's saying all the time but if i don't
hear a no from the guest directly
that's not a no like someone's team can
say no someone's assistant can say no
someone's pr team can say no but until
they say no personally it's not a no
okay but when they do say no then that's
a note yeah so then let's move how do
you deal with that type of failure yes
so if i deal with a failure where
someone meets me in person and gets to
know me no jay you're horrible you suck
like i don't want to deal with a monk
ever in my life yeah i would never go on
your show i'm never listening to you
never yeah then how do you deal with
that type of so i've heard you say this
i've said it a couple of times and i'm
sure it's been repeated a bunch of times
around how i genuinely believe failure
has feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy years maybe to prove
something wrong i've been there many
times and then you're like i felt good
for a moment yeah and then i feel empty
again totally and so that's the thing
about failure in the second half is you
have to see failure as an improvement if
if i'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has
made me more hungry taught me so much
more about myself and made me up my game
yeah and i think if failure doesn't make
you up your game it's the same as losing
in a sport
right you and you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you weren't
everyone is indicating enough there's
something you were missing yeah so you
go review the game film you check the
stats you see what could have done
better and you try to improve that for
the next game yeah and i think a lot of
people can do that in life but we're so
afraid to like go on the next game of
life like i got rejected once and it
hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah and keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh i'm just
going to give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
i think that's great mental training too
i think sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost then you don't
feel bad exactly that you don't feel
good sorry and and one of the things
before i dive into that question one of
the things that you reminded me of was
that the last dance documentary so
there's that season
that michael jordan everyone is
agreement in an agreement that he is one
of the best players to be playing and
they keep losing they didn't make a
fight they didn't make the finals they
lost
and then they realized they need to get
the team and they need to find i think
they bring in dennis rodman and then
start bringing in all these other
players that strengthen whereas if they
would have just said oh we got the best
player in the world we just keep doing
this
i'm not sure they would have got there
right but the coach phil jackson and the
team they had to adapt and so you're
saying why do we feel that pain in
rejection and how do we deal with that
i think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure
right we look at it as a complete
definition of us
right we're looking at it as as there's
that famous statement of like you know
failure is an event not a person right
and i don't know who said it but it's
one of those statements that that really
clicks like failure is uh an event not a
person whereas we start thinking we are
the failure like we say i am a failure
whenever you give out any energy
love
hate
anger
kindness
you will always get it back
one way or another
love is like a circle
whatever love you give out
it always comes back to you
i was just showing
sally uh facebook memory backstage
seven years ago
i love facebook reminders look at this
it showed me that i was speaking to this
little group of students
about seven mistakes people make in
their twenties
and it was a memory of a talk that i was
giving six and seven years ago i
released my first video five years ago
so six and seven years ago most people
didn't know who i was and what i was
doing i had an event in london
called conscious living it was on a
friday night in the city
and five to ten people would show up
every week that's it five to ten people
and i remember loving it and i remember
feeling so happy and so grateful that
five to ten people showed up and i feel
the same way about the first five to ten
people that followed me and commented on
my videos and i feel the same way about
the first five to ten people when i
finally got to meet them and i found
that
if you can love
one person if you can deeply feel
grateful for one person
then
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
will come from that but if you struggle
to be present and connected to that one
person
it's really hard
to be trusted by the universe with more
what is it that success looks like for
you and don't make it about a number
don't make it about an account of views
don't make it about a follower don't
make it about a size of home
because those things
are great for success
but they're not great for happiness my
measure of success is
can i wake up and do something i love
every day
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want another amazing brandenburg shard
video check it out right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there
did you look at your goals every day
this year every day did you look at your
goals every day this year it's such a
simple question every day i don't mean
once in a while every day if you didn't
my invitation to you is to consider the
fact that maybe